اذا كنت تعمل كثيرا لدينا خبر جيد بخصوص
ايام العمل واوقاته حيث اظهرت دراسه جديده
اجريت في المملكه المتحده نتائج مبهره
للعمل اربعه ايام فقط مقابله ثلاثه ايام
عطله في نهايه الاسبوع الدراسه التي
نشرتها شركه الابحاث البريطانيه شملت 61
شركه وحوالي 2900 عامل وخلصت الى ملاحظه
نجاح باهر في العمل بعد انخفاض الضغوط
بالنسبه للموظفين الذين حصلوا على وقت
شخصي اضافي ووجد الموظفون فرصه اكبر
للتقليل من الاجهاد وتحسين الصحه العقليه
والمزيد من ممارسه الرياضه ووقت اسهل
للنوم وقالت 56 شركه من اصل 61 كانت ضمن
هذه الدراسه قالت انها مستمره في نظام
العمل اربعه ايام في الاسبوع فيما اكدت
ثماني عشره شركه تغيير سياستها للنظام
الجديد بشكل دائم اما المو ظفون فقال 90%
منهم انهم يرغبون في استمرار العمل باربعه
ايام اسبوعيا وافاد 55% من الموظفين
بزياده قدرتهم على العمل بعد ان حصلوا على
يوم عطله اضافي اي ثلاثه ايام في الاسبوع